-My next guest
is an award-winning actor
who stars in the new series
"Jupiter's Legacy,"
which premieres this Friday
on Netflix.
Please welcome Josh Duhamel!
Yeah! Oh, my goodness. Wow!
Oh, my goodness!
Thank you for coming back
to see us, buddy.
I appreciate this.
I know you've been --
just finished filming a movie
with one of our favorites,
Jennifer Lopez.
How is -- How's J. Lo doing?
And that's really
what I want to ask.
-[ Laughter ]
-She's fantastic.
I mean,
I've known her for years.
And it just --
You know, it sort of came --
came to my attention
that the job became available,
and I got a chance
to, you know, meet with her.
And so it was like --
it was like, you know,
rekindling an old friendship
with an old friend.
But then we get to set.
You know, the Dominican is --
It's hot.
Yeah.
-And beautiful.
-Yeah.
So is -- so is J. Lo.
-Yes, exactly.
-So is Josh Duhamel.
Yeah, I mean --
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, thank you.
Thank you, Jimmy.
It was very hot.
And we're sort of on the run
from these -- these pirates
and these people that
sort of overtook the wedding.
And so I'm like this -- this --
I just crawled out of a river
half the time in this movie.
I'm completely soaked
and sweaty.
And she's just gorgeous
throughout the movie.
So I'm not sure
we're going to look like the --
the perfect couple half the time
because I'm, like, this
sweaty mess and she's, well --
I mean, she's J. Lo, so...
-No. I'm sure it will work.
I'm sure it will work.
You sent us a video,
and I got to say
it made me laugh so hard today.
I was watching.
It's a beautiful video
of the Dominican Republic.
Do you want to explain what
happened before we see it?
Or how do we set it up?
-So I had some time off.
And right below where we were --
where I was sort of staying,
near where my green room was,
was this beautiful little cove.
And earlier in the shoot,
it was this
perfectly calm, turquoise little
cove that I could jump --
I actually jumped off
this platform into the water
and swam over to the beach
and walked back.
Well, about a week later,
this place
was completely different
because it was now like --
The ocean was -- was
really tumultuous that day.
And the waves were crashing
like 30 feet in the air.
Well, this rogue wave comes up
as I'm videotaping this thing
and literally washed me almost
over the edge of this cliff.
And, you know, thankfully --
-I'm happy you're okay.
-Thankfully there's
this razor-sharp coral
that's there that held me up,
but it --
it turned me into hamburger
on many parts of my body
afterwards.
But it was one of the near-death
experiences in my life for sure.
-I'm only laughing
because I know you're okay.
But --
-Yeah.
-You guys got to see this video.
It is -- It's just --
I could see you --
I could see you filming,
and it was just a disaster.
Watch this.
Beautiful.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God. [ Laughs ]
That's my favorite shot.
[ Laughs ]
-Oh, my God.
-Holy...
Oh, my God.
Dude, the shot of the sky.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's like -- Wow!
Don't mess with Mother Nature!
You got rocked.
-I cannot believe
my phone survived that.
-Me neither.
-I can laugh about it now.
And I never told anybody.
You're the first person
I've shown that to because
if I had shown that to Lionsgate
when we were shooting it,
They would've -- I don't know --
They probably would have
kicked me off the movie.
-Yeah, I'm happy
that you saved it for our show.
That's what I --
I appreciate it.
I want to talk
about your Netflix series,
"Jupiter's Legacy."
This is a big superhero series.
Can you set it up for us?
-Yeah. It's a -- It's a script
that I read about
a year and a half ago.
Lorenzo di Bonaventura
sent it to me.
And I just loved the stor--
I loved more --
as much the superhero aspect as
I did the family aspect of it.
And it's really an examination
of the psychology
behind what it would be like
to be these people.
And there's an origins story
that starts in the late --
in the early '30s that goes --
And then we jump back and forth
to present time
so you sort of see
how they became who they are
and then what the repercussions
of that are 90 years later.
And -- And, you know, this guy
can fly around the world
in 12 seconds
and shoot laser beams
out of his eyeballs,
but he can't communicate
with his 20-year-old daughter.
And I found that
to be fascinating.
-Yeah. You do play --
You go all over the place.
Here's you at the age
of 120 years old that you play.
-Yeah. Obviously,
there's a muscle suit there.
I don't know if you know this,
Jimmy, but I don't normally
look that muscular in real life.
-Uh, yeah,
I don't know if anyone's
looking at your muscles
in this costume.
[ Laughter ]
Maybe I'm wrong.
[ Applause ]
-But, you know, there's
the makeup and the prosthetics
and the wig and the beard,
and then that muscle suit
and the cape and the suit
and all that stuff.
You really feel like
you've been through it --
like you've been through
90 years of battles.
And I'm very proud
of the series.
I think people
are going to love it.
-Yeah. I want to show everyone
a clip. It's great.
Here's Josh Duhamel
in "Jupiter's Legacy."
Take a look.
-There's a million things
you could have done.
You took the easy way out.
-Did that look easy to you?!
-Sheldon!
-Go!
You wait for me at the union.
[ Whoosh ]
Contact the Supermax.
I want to know
how Blackstar got out.
-On it.
[ Whirring ]
-You okay?
-No.
-Our son took a life.
After everything we've
taught him, he broke the code.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-Josh Duhamel!
"Jupiter's Legacy" premieres
this Friday on Netflix.